K
RUSSIA DUSTED
AMIC J ECC
ESPIONAGE. IT ALLS COMPLETELYIEE
YET TO EVENETTH AMERICANNTONY
Y. SAID THIS INOWN  NDOEING W RT
I SAIDER
THE EKHAT
EVEN BE RELEASED IMMEDIATELYS NF
MOSCOW BUREAUOR
U. S NEWS AND WORLD REPORT IN
1986 WN ND DETAINED
KSON FOR 13 DAYS,
EL A A SPY.
THANKS SO MUCH FORNI
SECRETARY BLINNPARING TO OFLY
DETENTIOICH WOULD TRGOO
RK. IT'S
QUICKLY
ENOUGHE? THE FACTT
IMPORTAN AND THA THEO ALL
EVOING
ON. RS FALSELY YOU OF BEING A D?
DID THEY JUSTCLAIM AND
LOCK YOU UP?MADE THE CLAD MEWERE
DETAINED JUSTSEEET UNION'S TO TS
HAD BEEN ATETH YOU AND THAT EMPE
OM. UM WHYDOOUNK RUSSIA FOR THES
THIS
AMERICAN JOURNALIST? ACCUSING
HIM OF ESPIONAGE.  DO YOU
THE SAMEUS ARRES?OR TS
ERD THEY
S
TO BE THE CASE WYO MAY W
TH
IN THE SAMEN, ANDGUIDED BY OF TS
CENTER THEY DETAINED, A E  A
LO,G HISTORYHAT STALISS EVAN COB
OR TO HIM AS HE SITS,THID.L W IH
THAT I DIDNY ACCESS
IN THESILD TYABOM WITH THATAKE O
THE FACT THATOTH RSI THAT
BE BEHIND WHY TDITHIS. I WNK THS
HELPFUL THAT G
I COUL TOUIN
RUSSIANAN T CREATED
ENAT PRISON.AS. THANKFULLY
AFTER DAYS  D, THIS MIKHAIL G
WAS PREST OF THE SOVIET
UNIONNHA
WITH VLADIMIR PUTIN HERE WHO
SE MORE THE
INNIKS, , ARE YOU
AT ILL NOT ESY OR AS SMOOLY
DID. NOT MAY NOT,
NIC,USEHE VERYED ALLIG